this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
right now you guys can get 25 off the
cost of a subscription more on them in
just a bit
in the early 1860s the territory of
colorado would have been the perfect
setting for a classic western movie
mexican farmers uneasily cohabited with
recently arrived american settlers in
gold prospectors the union cavalry and
u.s marshals patrolled the canyons
woodlands and gulchers searching for
bandits skirmishing with the native
nations or recruiting volunteers for the
ongoing civil war in the east but from
spring to autumn 1863 these lawmen would
be confronted with a whole new breed of
horror one we would normally associate
with another genre altogether the
territory settlers faced three seasons
of terror due to the murderous insanity
of the axemen of colorado felipe
espinoza described at the time as a
mexican bandit he achieved infamy as one
of the first if not the first serial
killer of the wild west
[Music]
nerio espinoza was born in 1827 in what
is today known as the el rito
unincorporated community in rio arriba
county new mexico he was the older of
five siblings one of them his brother
vervin was born in 1831 and he'd become
a trusted partner in crime there's only
sparse information about the early lives
of felipe and vivin and what we know is
that their parents were subsistence
farmers of legal means literacy was not
a given amongst these rural communities
yet at least felipe and bivin could read
and write filippo was known amongst his
neighbors for his impulsive volatile and
violent temper this worsened after the
mexican-american war of 1846-1848
after the war the united states acquired
large swaths of territory from mexico
including the lands where the espinosas
had settled the territory of guadalupe
dargo allowed mexican residents to
remain in the newly seeded lands but
washington also encouraged settlers to
travel west and start farming the same
territories inevitably simmering tension
and open conflict manifested between the
two communities known as hispanos and
anglos as a proud hispano felipe
resented the anglo-newcomers he saw them
as usurpers oppressors and enemies of
the true catholic faith both espinosa
brothers were indeed devoutly religious
and were members of the holy brotherhood
of the blood of our lord jesus christ
members of this paternity were also
known as penitents and provided
philanthropic help to the less fortunate
however some of their number also
indulge in extreme religious practices
such as self-flagellation it's not clear
if felipe inflicted such violence upon
himself but it appears that he did
inflict it upon others in 1854 the 27
year old espinosa decided he wanted to
marry but as he had no luck with the
local ladies he traveled south to the
village of kachid and abducted two
sisters secondina and eugenia aged 17
and 11 respectively thankfully he almost
immediately set free eugenia but he kept
the older sister with him for several
days mentally and physically abusing her
secondina finally escaped and returned
to her family quickly chased by felipe
but her father terrified by espinosa's
violent character convinced the girl to
marry her abductor we don't know if
their relationship developed into less
toxic patterns but we know for sure that
they went on to have three children in
1858 the espinosa extended family moved
from el rito to the san luis valley
southern colorado the espinosas settled
into a plaza or community of small farm
houses according to different sources
this plaza was either known as san
rafael or san judas and
we're gonna go with judas by april 1861
the american civil war had erupted
colorado was not yet a state rather a
territory and the ravages of war had not
yet reached the san luis valley
according to the census of the time
felipe and little brother vivin were
making a living as a brick maker and
farmer respectively yet around this time
it appears that the two brothers took to
banditry it is unclear who was the bad
influence or exactly what were their
crimes possibly cattle rustling but it
seems that they earned a reputation in
the press as desperate and lawless
for much of 1862 the espinosas were
occasional bandits amateurs if you like
but their criminal career was about to
take a sharp turn in december around
that time a priest from the town of taos
purported a gruesome robbery to the u.s
cavalry stationed in fort garland two
mars men had held up a wagon carrying
some of the priest's properties the
bandits looted the vehicle then seized
the driver juan gonzalez they tied the
poor man underneath the wagon and then
whipped the horses sending them
galloping across the rocky soil the
drivers head and face hit every bump and
stone on the path turning it into a
bloody pulp luckily he survived and was
able to identify the culprits the
espinosa brothers of san judas plaza
calvary lieutenant hart organized an
expedition in mid-january 1863
accompanied by ten horsemen and u.s
marshal george austin the lawman paid
two visits to felipe espinosa's
farmhouse the first time they pretended
to be on a recruitment mission most of
the cavalrymen were hispanos after all
so why not enlist them and then join the
union army in the civil war they've been
talked to the lieutenant quite civilly
apparently it's not clear why hot did
not arrest him and felipe then and there
instead the detachment left and returned
five days later this time hodd and
austin went straight for the arrest
locking felipe and vivin into their
house but then chaos broke loose
apparently the espionages had access to
a veritable arsenal which nobody had
cared to confiscate the two brothers
started firing from the windows with
pistols rifles and even bows and arrows
the cavalry shot back with little
success until hot ordered the house to
be set on fire at that point felipe and
bibin made a desperate sorde discharging
more and more arrows the lieutenant drew
his pistol and fired all of his rounds
missing every single time his second
pistol didn't seem to work so he threw
it to the ground in frustration and
that's when it decided to work a bullet
went off at that moment wounding hot on
the forehead in the meantime the
espionages were running away across the
frozen river canals marshall lost in
gave chase but it all slipped on the ice
man and beast crashed to the ground the
whole expedition had been a disaster the
two bandit brothers had disappeared into
the san juan mountains the marshall had
a broken leg the lieutenant had almost
shot himself in the brain and sadly a
corporal had been killed in the hail of
gunfire the army reacted harshly to the
debacle they completely burned down the
espinosa's farmhouse and confiscated all
of their belongings including their
livestock the entire extended clan was
left destitute as a result the incident
may be at the root of the darkness that
descended on colorado the killing rage
of the espinosa brothers alright we'll
get back to today's video in just a
moment first here's a word from today's
sponsor curiositystream curiositystream
is a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals think of it as the
netflix for nerds the hulu for history
buffs curiosity stream is available on
many platforms and web apps including
roku android xbox one smart tv's ios
chromecast amazon fire amazon kit on
apple tv it's also offered worldwide and
with its constantly updated content
you'll always have something to watch
for example this spring they added an
eight-part series called the bone
detectives it's great stuff now if you
like biographies though and i've got to
think you'd do because
you're maybe subscribed to this channel
you're at least watching it maybe head
over to curiositystream and check out
bio documentaries on alexander the great
william conqueror and so many more
famous names and you could also check
out american icons in nine part series
that tells the story of babe ruth ellen
and roosevelt mark twain and more go to
curiositystream.com for unlimited access
the world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and right now you
guys can use the promo code biographics
to save 25 off the cost of an annual
subscription which comes out to 14.99
not per month per year which is an
incredible deal so again
curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics 25 off making
it just 14.99 for the whole year and now
back to today's video
felipe and vivian stole two horses
during their retreat and made the
mountains their new home on the run from
the law according to later law it was
during one of the freezing nights
camping in the woods that felipe had a
vision a revelation the virgin mary
appeared in his dreams send as a
messenger from god the virgin had
ordered philippe to kill and kill again
until the blood of 600 anglos had been
spilled according to felipe's own later
writings he had lost six relatives
during the mexican-american war and he
would wash that trespass in blood of
course by killing a hundred anglos for
each espinosa whatever the motivation
the espinosas were hell bent on going on
a killing spree the hunting ground
initially was an area called sawmill
gulch just outside of canyon city it
later became known as dead man's gulch
the first victim was sawmill worker
franklin bruce shot on march 16 1863
according to some newspaper reports a
crucifix made of sticks protruded from
his bullet wound two days later it was
lumberjack henry harkins's turn his
co-workers found him one evening laying
inside his cabin he had been shot in the
forehead with the cult navy revolver he
also had two stab wounds on his chest
the most gruesome detail is that the
murderer had split his head in half with
an axe and they had inflicted further
blows to his skull scattering fragments
of bone and brain matter on the floor in
a matter of days the third victim was
found james adam and killed near
wilkerson pass west of colorado springs
during april the bloody espinosas
targeted the town of fair play jacob
binkley and abraham shoop were taken by
surprise as they camped outside the city
limits binkley was shot in the back and
died on the spot the shop was stabbed
three times and tried to escape but
collapsed after a short run three more
men were slain by the end of the month
one had been shot another one's head was
crushed under a rock a third one had
died with a bloody crucifix carved onto
his chest at the time lorman had not
connected these deaths with the two
bandits from san judas they believed the
culprit to be a lone wolf dubbed by the
press the axeman of colorado the
dwellers of the territory were gripped
by fear and suspicion any stranger
wandering into town could be the dreaded
killer an unlucky prospector mr foster
arrived in the town of alma at the wrong
time he was suspected of being the axe
man and beset by the gelanti mob the
townsfolk dragged him to a tree for
hanging he was saved at the last minute
by the oratory prowess of a minister who
subdued the crowd the governor of the
territory john evans offered a bounty
for the capture of the axeman he also
appointed colonel john chivington to
lead an infantry detachment to search
the region one of the officers involved
was lieutenant schoop brother of one of
the fair play victims he offered to
double the bounty out of his own pocket
but the axe man or we should say axe men
remained elusive it was later rumored
that they were helped by other brothers
of the penitentiary fraternity but it is
more realistic that they simply moved
very quickly along mountain paths
preying on lone travelers as they added
more victims to their tally the spree
killers refined their modus operandi in
the second phase of their descent into
madness they ditched the cult for
long-range rifles after stalking their
prey they cut them down from afar then
they descended upon the corpses like
vultures and set to work bodies were
found disemboweled decapitated and with
their hearts brutally removed or impaled
by wooden stakes however ghoulish the
two murderers were all too human and
sooner or later they would commit a
mistake
[Music]
a lumberjack called massie metcalfe was
driving a wagon down california gulch
when the espinosa suddenly appeared in
front of him without saying a word one
of them fired a shot hitting metcalf on
the left breast the lumberman fell
backwards into the wagon as the panicked
horses dashed wildly away felipe
espinoza later wrote in his diary killed
a man in a wagon
but he hadn't matthew had been saved by
a booklet of lincoln's emancipation
proclamation stuffed into his breast
pocket the pages had slowed down the
flight of the bullet saving mikkoff's
life finally there was a survivor
someone who could help describe and
locate the scourges of colorado metcalfe
reported the botched shooting and a
posse of eight men was quickly formed in
fair play led by john mccannon the posse
found a promising trail of hoofprints
close to california gulch following the
path the horsemen found a gruesome clue
a corpse butchered beyond recognition
well
almost one member of the posse
recognized the body because it belonged
to his brother mccannon and his men
continued riding for one day and one
night after daybreak they saw two horses
calmly grazing behind a screen of
campfire smoke the potty split into two
groups and approached the campsite they
crept through the grass fingers
nervously twitching by the trigger of
their guns when a human figure emerged
from a bush the men of fair play reacted
quickly too quickly perhaps without any
warning a shot rang out a red stain
bloomed on the man's side as he slumped
to the ground it could have been any
innocent traveler but in this case it
wasn't vivin espinoza cried out in fury
and returned fire with his cult more
rounds came flying in his direction
until one tore through his brain a
second figure came running from behind
the trees mccannon shouted to hold fire
believing him to be a member of his
posse this was felipe of course taking
advantage of the moment of confusion he
sprinted away before the fair play
gunman could take aim espinoza
disappeared into the woods pursued by
those who had killed his brother he
managed to evade capture until sundown
when the posse returned to the
encampment the nail lone axemen followed
them stealthily and shot one last time
before disappearing for good the bullet
missed the man who had killed bobin by a
mere three inches mccannon and his men
returned to fairplay with a valuable
load all the loot that the espionage had
stolen from their victims and felipe's
own diary based on the property seized
fair play authorities concluded that the
outlaws have killed at least 12 men but
in philippi's diary they found an unsent
letter to the colorado governor in which
he confessed to 32 victims
[Music]
with vivinded and felipe once more on
the run colorado breathed a sigh of
relief the summer was relatively calm no
more anglos were felled by the axe the
army and posses of settlers still roamed
the woods and mountains but felipe
managed to elude them even returned
several times to his family's dwelling
san judas plaza when visiting he dropped
further letters and portions of his
diaries confessing to the string of
murders and threatening further violence
he also took notice of his family's
condition following the cavalry raid in
january the espionage had fallen into
abject poverty it was during one of
these visits that felipe recruited a new
accomplice a nephew of which little is
known he may have been 14 and his name
may have been julio it's not even clear
why he recruited the boy was he looking
to initiate a new generation of
espionages to anti-anglo-violence or
maybe he just needed somebody to look
after the horses and the campfire
whatever julio's age or function felipe
returned to his murderous ways in autumn
1863 as the leaves started to fall so
too did the bodies in a matter of a few
weeks at least 11 killings were recorded
in southern and central colorado
attributed to espinosa on the 11th of
october 1863 felipe and julio had set up
an ambush at levator pass as a wagon
approached philippe attacked guns in
hand the wagon occupants a man and a
woman fled on foot in opposite
directions the espinosas ran after the
man called philbrook but soon lost track
of him on the mountainside they returned
to levator looking for the woman dolores
sanchez meanwhile she had hidden aboard
another wagon driven by two hispanos
felipe and julio held up that wagon as
well and upon finding that the drivers
were mexican they seemed eager to let
them go unharmed dolores could have made
it unscathed too had she not emerged
from our hiding place pleading for the
driver's lives her generosity of spirit
would not be rewarded alas felipe
allowed the two drivers to trot away but
would not reserve the same favor for the
lady with julio's help felipe bound her
tightly and then proceeded to rape her
the espionages abandoned her on the
mountainside as they galloped towards
more mayhem but help was on its way
pillbrook had reached fort garland and
alerted its commander colonel tap into
the situation tappan dispatched a patrol
who found laura in bad shape but still
alive back at the fort dolores and
philbrook were able to give a detailed
description of felipe tappan was ready
to strike back but he would not lead the
expedition he knew just the right man
who could locate the espionages and deal
the final blow
that man was named thomas tate tobin a
well-known tracker trapper and us army
scout who had fought alongside while
bill hicker and kit carson in the wars
against the native americans tappan
summoned tobin to the fort where he had
the opportunity to further question
philbrook and dolores with all the info
he needed the scout reared to start the
hunt immediately alone only upon
tappan's insistence did he accept an
escort of 15 cavalrymen with his uncanny
tracking skills tobin followed the trail
of the espinosas for three days and
three nights every broken stick every
bent blade of grass on the ground spoke
to tobin telling him where the bandits
were headed on the morning of the fourth
date the scout saw magpies flying in
circles in the distance an indication of
human presence this was confirmed by a
thin column of smoke lazily rising above
the treetops tobin ordered the soldiers
to stay put loaded his rifle dropped to
his stomach and crawled toward the
campsite two men sat by the fire with a
dead ox beside them the tracker
recognized them from the description he
had heard at the fort it was the
espinosas a snapping sound reverberated
through the forest maybe a breaking
branch it was enough to start a felipe
who reached for his rifle tobin reacted
on instinct barely taking aim he
released a slug hitting felipe on the
chest the killer fell backward onto the
campfire calling for julio to run away
the young nephew sped through the woods
a swift shadow appearing and
disappearing amongst the trees now tobin
took time to perfectly adjust his aim he
squeezed the trigger a second time and
julio's spine was shattered by hot lad
but felipe was still alive he crawled
across the forest floor and braced
himself against a tree he lifted his
rifle and shot against tobin but missed
the union cavalrymen now intervened
releasing a devastating volley felipe
espinoza the axeman sent by the virgin
to slay the anglos withered and jerked
against the tree bark as bullet after
bullet drained every drop of life from
his body but when he fell to the ground
apparently he still had one ounce of
life left inside him tobin walked slowly
to him and lifted him by the hair as he
pulled out his bowie knife tobin asked
him do you know who i am with his last
breath felipe muttered bruto
a brute then the brute's blade fell
twice upon the neck of espionosa days
later tobin returned to fort garland as
he strode into the office of colonel tap
and he announced
got them tap and asked got what tobin
opened the flower sack he'd been
carrying and pulled out the heads of
felipe and julio and thus ends the
narrative of felipe vivin and julio the
bloodiest banosas who may have been the
first documented serial killers in the
history of the wild west events grew to
acquire legendary status perpetuated by
one macabre relic felipe's head
preserved in a jar of alcohol was
exhibited as a traveling act before
ending up on the desk of a newspaper
editor then the head disappeared as the
memory of the espinosas faded from
history according to author adam jones a
preserved head which may have been his
was found in the early 2010s in the
basement of colorado's capitol building
it was incinerated before it could be
analyzed to this day many details
concerning the espionage's killings and
their eventual demise are still disputed
even the motivations behind their spree
are not entirely clear was felipe driven
to kill by delirious dreams and visions
of the virgin mary or was the violence
political in nature a revengeful rampage
against the anglo-oppressor maybe he was
just a vile psychopath who had strung
along his younger brother and teenage
nephew or was he an insurgent fighting
with the wrong methods against
depression perhaps felipe's rage was
fueled by all of these elements and the
raid on his plaza was just the last
straw that had tipped him over the edge
into darkness
so i hope you enjoyed today's episode
just before you leave today a quick plug
for one of my other shows the casual
criminalist it's a true crime show where
we dive into the stories of some of the
worst of the worst murderers serial
killers cult leaders we cover it all but
it's also pretty laid back doesn't take
itself too seriously and it could even
be called a bit fun it's the casual
criminalist there's a link below also
available as a podcast by the way
and thank you for watching
you